- [Instructor]
Three-dimensional facial scans
are being used to determine
how well patients have aged
in comparison to their peers.
So I actually like the word used.
It felt very clean.
I'm using only one word here,
and I was able to understand what it said.
Three-dimensional facial scans
are being used to determine
how well patients have aged
in comparison to their peers.
So I actually like this,
so I'm already inclined to no change,
but let's just look at the other choices
and hopefully feel a little bit better
why those would be bad choices.
Three-dimensional facial scans
are being usefully employed
to determine how well patients have aged
in comparison to their peers.
So usefully employed, it's not
really changing the meaning,
it's not giving us anything more,
and it's just more wordy.
It's a little bulky.
Three-dimensional facial scans are being,
instead of saying, are
being used to determine,
we're saying, are being
usefully employed to determine.
Well, I could just say used.
This is more concise, it's more clean.
If you can get the same meaning across
and do it in a simpler way
and a more concise way,
you should do it that way.
So I definitely not
like usefully employed.
Three-dimensional facial scans
are being put into action
to determine how well patients have aged
in comparison to their peers.
Well, put into action is
another way of saying used,
and used is cleaner, it is more concise,
it gets to the point.
While put into action,
put into action to determine how well,
it just, a little bit bulkier.
This wouldn't be, if someone wrote this,
it's not like they committed some crime
by writing put it, are being
put into action to determine,
but if I was editing that sentence,
I'd say, well, why don't you
just replace that with used?
It's much simpler and
cleaner, easier to read.
Three-dimensional facial scans
are being employed and utilized.
Once again, this is a very bulky way
of saying used.
So no need to add bulk to your sentences,
just to kind of add more words.
Three-dimensional facial
scans are being used.
That's very nice and clean.
So, oh I didn't, I haven't
answered the question,
that's an important part of it, no change.